the champions league final is one of the
biggest events on the global sporting
calendar
hosting the match brings prestige and
tourism among other benefits
paris will now host this season's final
after saint petersburg was stripped of
the honour by european football's
governing body uefa
they've also decided russian and
ukrainian club and national teams are to
play home games at neutral venues
fifa will have to decide whether or not
russia's world cup play-off in moscow
next month against poland will go ahead
as planned fifa has already spoken out
against the conflict
fifa expresses
hope for
a rapid
cessation
of hostilities
and for peace
in
ukraine
fifa condemns as well
the use of force
by russia in ukraine
and any type
of violence to resolve conflicts
meanwhile manchester united have
cancelled their 10-year sponsorship deal
with russia's national airline aeroflot
the airline had been united's official
carrier since 2013 and the deal was
thought to be worth more than 53 million
dollars
football is not the only sport taking
action formula one has cancelled this
season's russian grand prix the race was
due to be held on september 25th in
sochi f1 drivers are backing the
decision to boycott russia
like everyone said you know innocent
people
losing their lives you know people
losing their homes and and families and
don't have safe places to to live in
it's it's not right but well we can hope
that everything gets resolved in the
best possible outcome and way that is
that is possible and for now i think is
the right decision by
formula one not to go to russia but
ukraine has also been hit the national
basketball team's home match in kiev
against spain has had to be postponed
russian tennis star andre rublev made
clear his views on the matter after a
win in dubai on friday but unless there
is a swift end to the conflict more
sporting events are likely to be
postponed cancelled or moved to neutral
venues peter samut al jazeera